[Musik]
ohne worte
eigentlich müsste man das ohne worte
spielen 13 minuten ohne pause angesichts
dieses voll desasters auf offener bühne
der politischen landschaft an sich war
gut so dann lasse ich den hund sprechen
durch diesen hund spricht meine tochter
nun schon seit jahren möchte ich sein
und dieses mal sagte sind mir traut sich
jedoch nicht direkt anzusprechen müssen
sie im endeffekt seien sie spielten
medizin mit qualität und sie hatten mehr
so entschieden und gesagt sie uns gut
dass das letzte woche wegen krankheit
ausgefallen ist
weil papier dann musst du nicht mit
diesem menschen da diesem komischen man
dem komischen blauen anzusprechen
das ist doch gut ja also das gute daran
dass also weiter
und das hat mich an sigmar gabriel
erinnert der seine tochter vorgeschoben
hat als sie sein sagte sie er ließ sie
sagen ist doch gut dass der martin weg
ist dann martin schulz dann musst du mit
diesem mann mit den haaren ein gesicht
nicht mehr sprechen
da muss ich sagen habe ich gekotzt tut
mir leid dass davon entfernt sagen ich
gar nicht sagen aber da wurde mir
wirklich schlecht weil das habe ich
länger nicht gesehen eigentlich noch nie
gesehen dass ich plötzlich an einer
stelle so der charakter von einem
spitzenpolitiker einmal komplett frei
legt und was wir da gesehen haben das
ist aber dass hingegen gesagt hat ich
habe das so zu sagen ja geschlecht an
kopf und gliedern auf man dritte lager
auch verfolgt ich möchte dann habe ich
aber dann habe ich irgendwie gedacht
dann habe ich bei mir gedacht so dass
ich so alt wie cut out fort also für das
politische mit zur hartmann und
unschuldige kinderseele fing da
sozusagen an zu vereinen
mir liefen quasi die unsichtbar aber ich
dachte so wie kann man so naiv sind so
seien sozusagen wie kann man das
vorhaben dann dachte ich aber am sieg
und da die der kollege blume sozusagen
der ist es da der ist ja von innen mit
titan ausgekleidet arbeitet im
springer-verlag der weiß ganz genau wie
man sich in solchen situation zu
verändern ich hatte irgendwie ein
bisschen gehofft dass sie da aber jetzt
lerne ich auch sie waren menschlich
berührt ohne witz ja eine sekunde das
ist wirklich sigmar gabriel der bestimmt
auch ganz gutes rennen gemacht hat im
laufe seiner zeit gar keine frage hat
sich mit dem moment als an fett für
jedes weitere ministeramt das sieht er
läuft
sagen sie mal wie sie das finden
ich glaube die geschichte nicht
glaubst du mich ich glaube nämlich dass
hat er sich ausgedacht oder glauben sie
dass seine kleine maria maria doch sind
sie ja ich würde sie sind ja blöde als
der hund das ausgedacht das hat er sich
doch ausgedacht achja ich glauben sie ja
da hatten sie auch nach ich sag doch ich
sag doch ich habe schon noch nicht so
weit
also ja ich fand es unter uns aber er
ist der meinung dass er noch
außenminister bleiben kann
er denkt es geht einfach immer so weiter
ja das kann sein er hat erholt und wieso
zu weggekickt so und jetzt denkt er es
läuft einfach weiter für ihn weil er
macht es gut und das hat so etwas auch
sein man hat den sitz seiner körperform
angepasst und da kann er jetzt auch so
fliegt einfach weiter
er kommt gar nicht mehr runter muss auch
dann ja also jetzt einmal sigmar gabriel
hat die razzia fand ich ganz kurz wo wir
gerade von fliegen reden ich habe ja
auch persönlich auch flugangst seehofer
konnte nicht außenminister werden war da
nicht gerne fliegt wussten sie dass wir
uns noch einmal viele leute man könnte
aber auch sagen ein glück dass er nicht
gerne fliegt weil sonst wäre
außenminister gesagt hätte ein flugzeug
die eisenbahn auch platz gehabt im kern
schwer schweifen ab auf offener bühne
und das finde ich das im sommer seien
grundsätzlich sehr fragwürdig
beziehungsweise bedauerlich wenn ich
gestürzt ja daran ist dass das diese
b-note dieser saalschlacht bei der spd
nicht nur die spd schreddert sondern
auch verhindert dass irgendjemand mal
einen ruhigen blick auf diesen
koalitionsvertrag nehmen kann
in dem acht und schlechte sachen stehen
verschiedene menge gute sachen drin
insbesondere war wieder für die spd
klientel man so will also für die leute
die spd gewählt haben oder geneigt sein
könnten dass sie zu sehen und vielleicht
jetzt fdp gewählt haben oder ich weiß
nicht wer für die steht eine menge drin
von der rente die würden davon direkt zu
stabilisieren bis ich weiß nicht was und
das geht einfach komplett unter glaube
aber also ich habe gelesen dass ein eine
eine forschungsgruppe hat sich irgendwie
so algorithmen mäßig mit diesem
koalitionsvertrag beschäftigt die haben
den koalitionsvertrag praktisch so oben
rein getan erst ein russischer mit den
algen also ehrlich meine witz die haben
den koalitionsvertrag
lesen lassen von künstlicher intelligenz
und die künstliche intelligenz hat dann
gesagt dass dieser koalitionsvertrag zu
70 prozent
sozial demokratischen geist atmet das
fand ich eine interessante sache dass
das also geht man kann das machen
künstliche intelligenz kann jetzt
koalitionsverträge lesen und sie dann
bestimmten parteien zu ordnen und ich
glaube man braucht auch künstliche
intelligenz dafür denn natürliche
intelligenz würde sagen das kann zwar
sein aber ehrlich gesagt darauf kommt es
gar nicht so an
und jetzt sage ich ein ganz schwierigen
satz klar auf die inhalte es kommt ja
mit den jahren nichts gehört haben aber
in diesem fall kommt dass ich darauf
ankommt mal nicht 80 millionen leute
warten was in der regierung kriegen aber
da passt sie dann macht es egal sein
scheint jetzt nicht egal ihren die
gesamte wir leben gerade das ist ja
wirklich hier steht nicht spd aber wir
reden gerade entschuldigung ganz kurz
wir reden vielleicht nachher auch noch
mal über die cdu und die deutsche
parteienlandschaft und die
bundeskanzlerin aber wir müssen kurz
noch mal über die spd reden wir reden
darüber dass die spd scheißegal was in
diesem koalitionsvertrag drinsteht aus
dieser koalition nur noch als flachste
briefmarke rauskriegen kann in der
süddeutschen zeitung meine alte alma
mater steht seit drei monaten drin
die spd muss in die große koalition
richtig sie die schreiben sich die
finger wund um diese parteien die große
koalition zu drücken und sagen dann
gleichzeitig paradoxerweise muss die spd
dann aber auch echt an ihrer identität
arbeiten wo ich sagen kann wann ist
zugleich wird es nicht funktionieren
denn eintracht gleich ein schalter
herhalten schon ein scholz daher und
sagt also wir werden uns also 30 prozent
halte ich für eine total realistisch sie
laden den begriff der spd der den
begriff identität der spd falsch
aufgekommen sie in ihrer kleinen
logischen kette die genau aus und hat
wieder besteht zum falschen ergebnis das
problem der spd ist und nicht zu
regieren
sie kann durchaus weiter regieren heißt
ja gezeigt dass sie es kann
das problem ist nicht dass sie dirigiert
sondern und deshalb sinkt 10 umfragen
sondern sie hatte regiert und ist danach
in einen wahlkampf gegangen und hat all
das dementiert was sie in der regierung
zuvor erreicht hatte und wem soll man
das dann glauben wenn sich jemand
hinstellen sagt wir haben zwar viele
jahre lang sozialdemokratische
sozialpolitik gemacht denn wir hatten
auch das ministerium und der hat unsere
stärkste frau andrea nahles drauf das
essen aber im prinzip geht es in diesem
land sehr ungerecht zu was du heißt dass
die sozialministerin offenkundig dort
lässt genauso viel besser stattdessen
viel besser zu sein
wir haben vier jahre regiert mit angela
merkel angela merkel ist eine sehr sehr
gute kanzlerin das land ist unter der
regentschaft von angela merkel sehr weit
nach vorne konnten wir waren daran
beteiligt und jetzt möchten wir angela
merkel ablösen weil wenn wir es alleine
machen wird es noch besser
das sind total glaubwürdiges konzept das
funktioniert bestimmt richtig gut
ironie aus das wird nicht funktionieren
dass nämlich auch in der vergangenheit
die vergangenheit ist es ja nicht
probiert worden in der vergangenheit ist
ja immer gesagt worden wir haben das und
das gemacht das finden wir aber jetzt
doof und darum weil bis jetzt ganz
anders machen dazu brauchen wir neue
mehrheit so ein quatsch
außerdem treten sie ja nie wieder als
spd wenn sie in die regierung jetzt geht
und danach wählen geht ja nicht mehr
gegen angela merkel an
naja und sind ein weiterer grund in der
regierung zu gehen das begreifen sich
das begreift auch kevin das gummibärchen
entschuldigung kevin kühnert juso chef
der eine groko kampagne macht er
begreift nicht dass er in der opposition
zerrieben wird zwischen afd und
linkspartei und das hatten wir schon ein
paar mal dass diese beiden gruppen sich
natürlich treffen bei den kleinen leuten
von ihren vermeintlichen oder
tatsächlichen bedürfnissen ich hab ja
und er wird zerrieben
ich habe das kitze hier gemacht die kann
man jetzt bei seinem gewissen sehen ja
das sind meine zähne den habe der linke
eine schlechte ferien hier haben sie
praktisch eine sollte dies so ein
bisschen höher und dann haben sie hier
noch ein paar andere sollen die sind
alle mehr oder weniger gleich groß das
ist die deutsche parteienlandschaft am
ende der ära merkel hat die cdu knapp
über 30 prozent was ehrlich gesagt auch
für cdu verhältnisse ich kleine echt
ganz diesem namen ist auch für die
erderwärmung zu und alle an und für
händler vorsichtig kein stress jetzt
hier nicht auf trump machen ja so also
was hat die frau unter einem hierfür
abschafft hinterlassen die elfen
parteien mannschaft ist im prinzip
eingeebnet und dann wäre die ganze zeit
über die spd sie haben das schon auch
mitbekommen dass die leute wie röttgen
oder rühr oder koch ja dass wir alles
abgedeckt bei der cdu und den kompletten
abgesägten das sind die untoten
das sind leute wieder rausgegangen sind
kann man manche einer läuft quasi noch
mit seiner lebenden hülle hierdurch
parlamentsviertel und durch den konsum
durch kanzleramt kompaktes die hand der
der untoten raus und sagen irgendwie die
cdu wassertröpfchen gesagt ist ein
delta auf inhaltsleer inhalts entleert
und saint clair
die haben das gleiche problem wie die
spd dass die ära merkel jetzt machen sie
das mal nicht so klein ich versuche
jetzt mal sagt asmus rausziehen ich
frage sie das jetzt wahr ohne spaß wäre
eine offene frage wie kann es sein dass
am ende dieser kanzlerschaft die eine
sehr spezielle war weil die frau hatte
in sehr speziellen politikstil man das
gefühl hat dass diese beiden großen
volksparteien inhaltlich entkernt sind
ja der einheits mehr geschadet als der
anderen und die ganzen anderen parteien
alle mehr oder weniger gleich groß sind
plötzlich was denn hier eigentlich
passiert
das ist passiert es gab zu oft große
koalition da sind wir uns einig
mittlerweile gibt es fast gar keine
andere option mehr ist es ja versucht
worden einer weiteren großen koalition
aus dem wege zu gehen indem man jamaika
verhandelt hat also die koalition cdu
fdp und grüne
das haben dann die kleineren parteien er
platzen lassen von csu des fdp außerdem
die angela merkel platzen lassen auch
wenn es quasi unter ihrer verantwortung
geschehen ist und sie können ihr nicht
also ich bin bestimmt nicht der
pressesprecher sie können ihr nicht die
veränderung der parteienlandschaft aber
so zur schuld oder zu lasten der schiffe
nicht der chefin ist sie die chefin von
der parteienlandschaft sie ist die
chefin einer partei und sie hat ja ein
gehöriges teil ihres erbes würde darin
bestehen das ist die afg gibt aber was
das mit den grünen oder mit der
linkspartei oder mit der fdp
rein raus und dann auf die halbe höhe
gemacht hat das ist doch nicht angela
merkels schuld oder versäumnis sondern
da hat sich was getan und die fdp und
die spd die ihr der zweite große pohl
war hat es einfach selber fast ich
glaube ja erleben große koalition die
ihr leben etwas anderes wir erleben eine
eine de facto einheitspartei von cdu und
spd
wo die unterschiede inzwischen so
marginal sind das sagt selbst ich ja das
tut mir echt weh das zu sagen
die unterschiede sind so marginal dass
die leute das nicht mehr verstehen warum
sie die spd wählen sollen wenn sie die
cdu wählen können und das ist ja auch
deshalb jetzt noch mal auch heute gegen
mendig auch als konservativer cdu sicht
eine katastrophe
deshalb hat die cdu aber auch nur noch
30 prozent nur wenn sie die zusammen
zählen wenn sie sagen spd und cdu
zusammen
und sie kommen man jetzt so auf halber
46 80
da muss man sagen diese dieser
einheitspartei die ist eigentlich steht
sehr gut da
deshalb würde ich eigentlich votieren
für eine vereinigung von cdu und spd ist
aber das ist ja nur unter anderen
ländern
sozusagen der hna tische deutsche
einheitspartei das müssen wir uns nicht
bieten lassen christ ist
sozialdemokratische deutscher als
parteilich guckt mal in ganz prinzip das
heißt deshalb batterien ein
christsozialer sie reden den sound der
regel die immer argumentieren will das
ist sowieso alles eine system soße und
nur ein beispiel
und wenn die cdu mit der fdp regieren
könnte wenn sie starke nur wir haben
genügend leute diese beiden gruppen da
gibt es die steuersenkung ja wenn sie
die spd wählen können sie mindern weil
ich hätte sitzt auf toilette war das ist
ja genau das im moment wenn sie die spd
wählen können sie eine steuersenkung
verhindern wie gerade geschehen der
großen kultur weil diese partei dann
eine sperrminorität hat wenn man so will
und dann könnte das ist die
unterscheidung an weltanschaulichen
punkten es gibt links oder rechts noch
es ist nur verwischt es ist nur deshalb
verwischt weil an den rändern mit der
linkspartei und der afg zwei extreme
sind die links und rechts diskreditieren
auf eine bestimmte art und weise zeit
ist um
und ob du recht hast auch nicht sagt ihr
gleich das licht aber eine sache möchte
ich ganz sozusagen ein gutes hat dieser
tag heute der nächste woche soll der
rest ist noch nicht frei kommt aber
demnächst frei das ist doch jedes mal
eine gute nachricht da recht auf stadt
[Musik]